mach ich mir ja nehmen uns noch mal ein
bisschen mit in die gedankenwelt beider
seiten wenn du auf der einen seite mit
den beiden anhängern spricht wie sicher
sind sie sich sieht zumindest so aus als
seien sie sich ziemlich sicher
und was ist mit den tramp anhängern wenn
du mit denen sprichst haben die
überhaupt noch ein bisschen hoffnung
also wir probieren jetzt gerade mal ganz
kurz präsident wir probiert einmal rüber
zu kommen sind das tram klage wir
schauen auf uns die polizisten durch
lassen
das heißt sie sollen da hinten lang
gehen das machen wir
schaut mal hier hinten gibt es glaube
ich ein wenig leid also wir kommen jetzt
hier an der stelle nicht weiter
aber das macht sich sollten also das
lager von donald trump und ich sage euch
eins wir haben diese menschen in den
vergangenen drei wochen begleitet wir
haben sie gesehen an der ostküste in den
wüstenstaaten und an der westküste und
es ist in unser wahlsendung ein ein
guter begriff für mich gefallen nämlich
der des personenkults und das ist genau
dass diese menschen
sie leben ein stück weit für donald
trump und nur weil donald trump
womöglich irgendwann nicht mehr im amt
ist bedeutet das nicht dass dieses diese
bewegung beruf mit der magath trennen
wie sie sich selbst nennen dass der
damit erledigt ist und das wird
sicherlich etwas paul was wir in den
nächsten monaten in den nächsten jahren
genau beobachten müssen selbst wenn
selbst wenn donald trump eines tages
nicht mehr im amt ist was passiert mit
diesen ich glaube 60 millionen menschen
die ihn allein bei dieser wahl wieder
gewählt haben
die verschwinden ja nicht und nur und
und und was wird auch aus der familie
trump es gibt jetzt schon die gerüchte
dass donald trump vielleicht einfach
2024 noch einmal antritt
es gibt seine kinder also da einst habe
ich kann mir ganz sicher sagen es bleibt
absolut spannend hier den usa und wir
sind ja noch ein bisschen hier und
beobachten dass wir sind bild und wir
liefern dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier und
vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren